what could go wrong i'm going to make a
scientific guess
a lot of death oh
dude he's steaming so i'm pretty sure i
know how they're getting the sparks how
i want to know is there anything to
break down here like this is a good time
thanks to expressvpn for sponsoring this
video find out how you can get three
months free by clicking the link in the
description box below
guys and gals welcome back we're here
with ghee da silva
for stuntmen react we actually found a
secret clip
that none of us know about yeah for real
it's crazy and i can't wait to break it
down with you guys because i've never
seen this thing before
we've told this story a lot in the
channel but we met gee when we were
working on marvel rated r
and we're like hey guys let's see what
we're working on and we pulled the scene
he's like
that's me like that was you
i was like yeah that's me like well you
want to
do the voice of yourself dying
and i was like of course
and now we're friends and i win that
smash all the time
no you don't nico he's so good he's the
best in the office he's better than dean
gee texted christian saying oh
everyone's got to be practicing like i'm
just going to laugh at that because
i don't need to practice oh goodness
you're going to feel it you're going to
feel it it's going to be so easy i'm
going to three stock you so fast let's
shake on this okay
okay like maybe the end credits of this
episode if i three stalk you you have to
put it in
all right okay
all right let's react to some stunts and
to some awesome clips
so the clip we're going to start with is
from the show which is a film from 1922
starring a guy named larry
seven it's pronounced semen i don't know
larry's a little overshadowed by buster
keaton and charlie chaplin but the end
of this film
has some gnarly train stunts
this is like super cartoony the way it's
moving all quick this is kind of weird
about like this old black and white
stuff it's super cartoony but the stuff
they're doing is
so death-defying
[Music]
wow imagine just having to trust that
your performer is going to
save your life or you'll die look at
that yo he's just crossing this
train like that
dude he's steaming no
yo they didn't sit down for months after
that oh you're ready for a stunt
[Music]
nice matrix and a fight on the what
oh my god one day one day i'll get to do
something like that
oh it's the end of speed oh my god
keep going
i think there's a hidden cut there but
man that would hurt there was a cut
there but still
he jumped off the back of that is that a
dummy i mean maybe
maybe i could also see it just him doing
it that's about 15 feet
maybe more dude oh my god like they cut
it but he did jump
off the damn train if he's doing a
header off at the top of that train
there's definitely a pad at the bottom
in between
there has to be dude to be able to line
that up you're trying to line yourself
up
to an invisible crash pad yep because
there's a train in here you don't
see it so you're like i think it's right
here if you
miss that you're gonna break your back
the ultimate trust fall this stuff is so
bonkers there's like some true fast and
furious stunts but for real right yeah
[Music]
so much trust man oh my god yo why is
this guy
not respected we should all know his
name maybe it's his last name
it was because it was last night
[Laughter]
all right larry
[Applause]
oh it was a dream it was all a dream all
a dream
have you guys seen i saw the devil this
reminded me of it there's a crazy car
stunt in that
i'm still ready for whatever's going to
happen dude drift it
catch him
yes
all right man yeah a little disappointed
yeah that was a cool stunt i guess yeah
it reminded me it wasn't
good i remember it not being so cut up
right seeing adventure brothers or brock
just like sets himself up and does a
little tai chi
this is way better dude this is like
janky bravo yep exactly that's
entirely what's parodying
dude he puts his arm out into position
for landing on the seat like there's a
steering wheel hand
oh wait that's what that is yeah that's
the arm on the seat
oh my god that's the best thing i've
ever seen
oh my goodness that's so great
all right okay so speaking of car stunts
christmas is coming around the corner i
rewatch one of my favorite christmas
movies of all time good old
griswold family christmas chevy chase in
his prime he he's so good in this movie
man like everything he does
we're going to press on and we're going
to have the half happiest christmas
since bing crosby tap dance with danny
okay oh yeah the beginning of this movie
has a car stunt that blows my mind every
time i see it
alright here it comes dude this oh
oh my god look at that clearance that's
ridiculous
go back under go back under please go
[Laughter]
wrong
a pretty good time that was crazy how
sketchy is that how like what do you
have to do super sketchy
what could go wrong i'm going to make a
scientific guess a lot of death can we
just can we just accumulate
stubborn dead yeah that's that's what
could go wrong
it just seems so sketchy because the
clearance on both sides seems like a
foot yeah no
you can't mess up that's perfect that is
like perfect right there that's
at least two stunt drivers knowing
exactly what it is that they're doing
and trusting in one another completely
you would start with rehearsing probably
at a slow speed and just matching speed
and just seeing next to each other how
much space you have
making sure that you're not over pushing
or under pushing until they get to the
point where it's picture ready which i'm
assuming it's probably like 30 miles
an hour that seems fast the process of
working up to this is like the same
thing that you did for the magic carpet
yeah i would say so especially because
there were other cars that we had to
deal with yeah we had to practice
matching speeds and then we would speed
it all up then we go back to
adding a new element and go back to our
original starter speed and then work our
way back up which is probably the best
way to build confidence and
to build trust amongst your fellow stunt
peers you have to know your car really
well
to know how close you can get to
something right and if this stunt man
doesn't drive this car
normally every day which probably
doesn't he doesn't is he gonna have to
just like
practice with that car for a month or so
yeah let's say they probably
were rehearsing this for at least two
weeks the moment you get into a vehicle
or on a bike you probably have a good
couple of minutes to get accumulated to
seeing how it works you want to check
the brakes
if it's a stick shift you want to know
how good is the clutch
how good does it shift over you find the
things that are wrong because more than
likely the car that you're going to get
is going to be a beater so you want to
figure out all the things that are wrong
with it before you actually
are called to do action it's interesting
that they give you the crappiest cars
for the most dangerous stunts
crazy
the black panther himself is coming back
to the studio not to watch stunts
but to do stunts with nico ren and
myself he's going to specifically teach
us
how to fall without killing ourselves
without breaking bones without hurting
ourselves
we are very very excited for this and i
hope you guys are excited too and if you
are
hit that subscribe button so you don't
miss out on the episode
i'll see you guys then let's get back to
the stunts all right so my second
favorite christmas movie of all time
it's a close battle for first place it's
jingle all the way yeah
put some respect on his name and sinbad
you know what i like to do i like to
walk up in that office
grab one of those guys
sinbad makes that movie it is so funny
dude
this scene right here is amazing oh
relax buddy
i'm not about to hit a santa clause
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
ah
freaking boss santa
is that what's his name on audrey's a
giant that is andre the joke no it's not
a big show
the big shout out
dude this guy is massive the fact that
he makes arnold look small
i know it's crazy
that's like punching wes
man i don't even understand is there
anything to break down here like this
was a good time clint just wanted to
brighten our mood a little bit i just
wanted to watch it
with you guys can we watch it again what
does this movie does right here what
does this roll
it's like a bowling pin how do you do
that a lot of b-boys do it i used to do
it back in the day
you would roll back straight legged so
you'll pike and you would
drop down and use the inertial momentum
once you feel
you're at your head you use it to pop up
and you keep your next step so that way
you don't like do that
because that's not gonna be fun and then
you you push through your feet as hard
as you can to the sky
and then you're just gonna belly flop
like he did and then that's why they cut
to him getting to a stand up
it's perfect though like it's so
symmetrical yeah it's nice
and so cartoony how do they send this
guy
this is straight on the line it's just a
dull screen
so they have them picked at the hips and
they have one on his back
which is connected to a line that goes
all the way back that way so he can
track
and then they're pulling him through the
boxes dude it's him the whole time
yeah that's a dog
[Applause]
that was a fun one why are there not a
whole bunch of santa fights i feel like
there's
got to be another santa fight this isn't
the only santa fe is there hey
if you guys have any santa fights you
want us to react to leave a comment down
below i'm looking for him like this is
the only one i know of leave a comment
we'll check it out
watch it here on the show so me and gee
randomly found this
clip let's jump into it and see what's
up
this is the most 90s looking with the
colors and everything and then you got
like the jackie denim jacket
mm-hmm and the hair the jackie hair too
that's amazing oh my god dude that's a
freaky that's a real chainsaw they might
be doing the whole like chain off the
chainsaw thing
it rips through the floorboards
oh my god it's pretty sweet that's
really dope
this is really like what
yeah there's no way they're doing this
with actual chains
there's no way some shots are using a
real chainsaw yeah like you can't do
that without a real chainsaw right there
is she just asleep i'm not watching this
don't you hear this
oh that's it there it goes there it goes
brutal i've never seen a chainsaw fight
before same
yeah that's pretty dope so i'm pretty
sure i know how they're getting the
sparks in the chainsaws
how i want to know so one of the things
you can do for chainsaws you can just
take the chain off
yeah there's no way they're doing this
with actual chains
there's no way for something like this
you know you sometimes see shots of
spinning
i'll bet there's chains they have that
are dulled chains that have little
pockets of the kind of metal that sparks
but that only works to have a moving
chain and for a lot of shots for the
chainsaws are hitting each other the
chain will just jam
and so one of the things they've done
for sparks is they actually electrify
them so they touch
sparks happen from the electrification
that's cool this is incredible
beautiful 540 into a drop slash yo
some wushu right there so chainsaw have
a moving chain on it it's hard to tell
hard to tell
i don't think i don't think so i think
it's yeah he just he just has squibs on
him you know
power rangers moment here hit him with a
blade without the chain turn on the
squibs
yeah i feel like for half of these shots
though they're legit sawing stuff down
a lot of this stuff is pre-scored yeah
i'm wondering like is it scored without
the blade and they're just chopping it
dude this moment when he saws his shoe
off
look at that dude that was wild that's
crazy
that maybe you could fake but you see
the wood particles shooting out
you can see the pre-scored floor there
all that debris and sawdust is there to
sell
it coming through yeah chaos yeah and
it's probably a dummy shoe
actually you can see how the shoe gets
thrown to the side by the moving chain
yeah
it probably doesn't have blades on it no
and then later on selling the cut foot
it's so well edited those four shots are
perfect
i hadn't stumbled across a fight as
crazy as that
i don't remember the last time oh my god
what's up guys i'm here to tell you
about our sponsor expressvpn and how
they can help you protect your internet
privacy
it's very important a lot of us are
stuck at home these days and that means
a lot more of our lives are taking place
online everything from entertainment to
our work to private correspondence and
transactions
advertisers internet service providers
and hackers all can get access to this
information when it's unencrypted
that's why using a vpn is so important
because it puts a secure tunnel around
your data so that bad actors can't get
to it and the best vpn service out there
is expressvpn they're the most secure
have the fastest speeds like
like really fast and 24 7 customer
support it's also really easy to use
you just choose a location and hit one
button to connect it's really that
simple
not only do they keep your data secure
but they also let you explore
new entertainment i'm sure many of you
have run out of shows that binge at home
and with content unblocking expressvpn
allows you access to content that is
normally unavailable in your area
if i wanted to watch all the studio
ghibli movies without expressvpn for
example
i couldn't because they aren't available
on netflix in the us
but if i switch my location to the uk i
now have hours of beautiful animation
available for my viewing pleasure
there are thousands of other shows and
movies that i can access in other
regions the same exact way
go to expressvpn.com corridor crew
that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
corridor crew to find out how you guys
can get three months free
that was really fascinating and it's
always interesting seeing what kind of
new insights that you bring
when you join us yeah at the beginning
it's like all about like how do you take
this thing how do they do that
it's called the gooch but now it's how
does a leading man influence
the set when he's not on camera acting
like there's so many
interesting unique things that you are
bringing to us here with your knowledge
so
thank you again for joining us oh man
thanks for having me and
yeah i love sharing it so i can tell i
can tell it's fun
it's fun talking about the stuff with
you like you were saying it's fun to
just geek out about
clips that you love oh you love this
clip too right it's the best and like i
drove here this morning with a smile on
my face because i knew
like he was coming over and it's going
to be an awesome day so thank you
i was actually super hyped for today
yeah it was gonna be a fun day i'm not
the only one thank goodness
if you guys would like to see more geese
stuff you can follow him on instagram at
yex da silva you post cool clips and
it's a lot of fun thanks man i really
try you know again this is probably one
of the only platforms i really get to
genuinely nerd out and geek out with
fellow geeks and nerds that enjoy the
same things i love so
thanks for having me i'm always down to
come back any time and any time love
having you well
it's time i three stock use smash bros
so you can just repeat the clip now
do the links go here go there if right
now there's like another like
30 seconds on the move video then you
know something interesting's about to
happen if the video's ending right now
then you know that he didn't get three
stalked
get the sticks let's go
all right you real quick you want to you
want to bring a camera you want to get
this